هناك بعض الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ
يقولون حان الوقت لتجميد
التعاون السعودي بشأن العلاقات مع روسيا هل
البيت الأبيض موافق على ذلك
أعتقد أن الرئيس كان
واضحا جدا أه أن هذه
علاقة أه نحن بحاجة إلى
الاستمرار في إعادة تقييم ذلك  نحتاج
لأن نكون مستعدين
للعودة وبالتأكيد في ضوء قرار أوبك
أعتقد أن هذا هو مكانه
وهو على استعداد للعمل مع الكونجرس
أه للتفكير في ما
يجب أن تبدو عليه تلك العلاقة للمضي قدمًا مرة أخرى
ليس لدي  أي قرارات للإعلان أو
التحدث اليوم ولكن أعتقد أنك ستجد
أن الرئيس أه خيب ظنًا واضحًا
من قرار أوبك
أه وسيكون على استعداد للعمل مع
الكونجرس كما نفكر في ماهية
العلاقة الصحيحة مع السعودية  تحتاج الجزيرة العربية
إلى المضي قدمًا ، ما هو
الجدول الزمني لذلك أعني أن لديك شتاء
قادمًا ، لديك روسيا تضرب
البنية التحتية للطاقة في أوكرانيا ، لديك
أوروبا على وشك أن تمر بطاقة صعبة
إذن ، ما هو الجدول الزمني
للنظر في هذا التعاون السعودي ،
أعتقد أن الجداول الزمنية الآن وأعتقد أنه
سيكون على استعداد لبدء
هذه المحادثات على الفور ،
لا أعتقد أن هذا
شيء يجب أن ننتظره  أو يجب أن تنتظر
بصراحة تامة منذ فترة أطول من ذلك بكثير ،
لقد ذكرت أن الشتاء يأتي بوضوح
أن هذا عامل هنا ولكن الأهم من
ذلك بالنسبة للرئيس أنه
يتعلق حقًا
بأمننا القومي ومصالح أمننا القومي
وهؤلاء هم الشعب الأمريكي وهذا
ما سيفعله  استمع إلى معظم أه
نبيع أه كميات هائلة من
الأسلحة للسعوديين أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى
إعادة التفكير في تلك المبيعات أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى
رفع الإعفاء الذي
منحناه لعصابة أوبك بلس هذه من مسؤولية تثبيت الأسعار في الولايات المتحدة
أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى النظر
في وجود قواتنا أه في أه في
الشرق الأوسط والمملكة العربية السعودية ، أعني
الاستماع لسنوات ، لقد نظرنا إلى
الاتجاه الآخر حيث أن المملكة العربية السعودية
تم تقطيعها مع الصحفيين.  -
قمع سياسي هائل لسبب واحد
أردنا أن نعرف أنه عندما تراجعت الرقائق
عندما كانت هناك أزمة عالمية ،
فإن السعوديين سيختاروننا بدلاً من
روسيا ، حسنًا ، لم يختاروا
روسيا ، بل اختاروا دعم
الروس لزيادة النفط.  الأسعار التي يمكن
أن تؤدي إلى كسر
تحالفنا في أوكرانيا ، ويجب أن
تكون هناك عواقب لذلك ، سواء كان ذلك
لرفع حصانة الكارتل أو ما إذا
كان يعيد التفكير في وجود قواتنا هناك ،
أعتقد أن علاقتنا الأمنية
قد حان الوقت للاعتراف بأن السعوديين
ليسوا كذلك.  يبحث عننا ، لقد مرت
ثلاثة أشهر منذ أن التقى الرئيس بايدن أه
مع ولي العهد السعودي والآن شارك
رئيس الوزراء محمد بن سلمان
أن قبضة القبضة الشائنة هناك
تثير ضجة أن الرئيس لا يزال يدافع عن
هذا الاجتماع هذا الأسبوع قائلاً إنه لم يكن
يتعلق بالزيوت فقط  حول مجموعة كاملة من
الأشياء الأخرى ولكن بالنظر إلى قرار هذا الأسبوع من
قبل أوبك ، ما رأيك في
لعب الرئيس بايدن ،
لا أستمع  لدي أي مشكلة مع الرؤساء الأمريكيين الذين
يجتمعون مع أصدقائنا أو
خصومنا ، وأعتقد أنه من الواضح أن العلاقة في الوقت
الحالي قد انهارت لكنها
انقطعت في ظل الرؤساء الديمقراطيين
والرؤساء الجمهوريين ، لذلك
لن أنتقد أبدًا رئيسًا أمريكيًا لمقابلته
مع شخص آخر.  القائد فمن
الواضح أننا لم نحصل على ما كنا
بحاجة إليه من ذلك الاجتماع
بين الولايات المتحدة ولكن